for me the fall of the berlin wall
was one of the most beautiful moments in
european history of the 20th century it was a
moment when europe as such in
fact re becomes somehow
conscious of its unity which what  'we must
not forget before europe was
cut off west and east a part under the
american umbrella the other part under
soviet domination and europe in
fact you didn't really exist any more
in there well there were the communities
etc but  it was only at the end of the
cold war that we became
aware again that here we are,
Europeans and we here on this side of
the berlin wall me, I'm Dutch, we're
in belgium,
we rediscovered all the clunkers that
had people  on the other side of
the Polish Iron Curtain where we see Czechs
who considered themselves European and who
want to come and join us and we
had forgotten them a little bit